so then when I have a look over here
right can I break it apart like I did
before we broke it apart with the real
component can I do it with this guy
can I write this what do you think do
you reckon it's doable
or am I breaking rules hmm now this is
what I mean by right you have to pause
remember and really think I could really
quickly just tell you an air time I
could say yes you can no you can't
right but what's more important like if
all I give you is a rule then if someone
asks you later on like you leave here
and you're like oh what can you do with
this you'll go from this line to the
next line and if someone say but why did
you do that pretty much the best answer
you can give is because we still we're
told me I could write because there was
some accepted Authority that gave me
that but you don't need an authority
like me you can work out yourself
Justin I see you kind of thinking what's
your instinct yes we cannot no we can't
the modules of ie is one we'll come back
to that in a second so that's if that is
if this is true then I will use that
fact but right now I'm still a step
behind that I don't I haven't
established that this is true yet what
are you thinking no what you reckon see
you had an answer already before I
started on the board you got to like a
final line based on your final line do
you think this is an okay operation to
do is it consistent with yours yeah do
you reckon this is okay hmm what do you
reckon to her should we do I mean I did
it with real numbers right except while
I totally agree with that as a general
problem solving strategy you can see
that strategy in and of itself by itself
it doesn't cut it right it's like if I
can do it with real numbers that does
not mean I can do with complex numbers
okay so let me make you feel better yes
we can't do it so therefore what Justin
said is correct
the winner for F marries the modulo
serve I let's think about what that
means right because um this is where
some of your definitions
for the absolute value they sort of
break down when you go into a complex
world right but you can't think of it as
the positive version of because I is
neither positive nor negative it's not
on the real number line right so there's
I but of course the modulus of AI is
just how far is that from the origin
which of course is one unit right now
just a little minor thing here when you
go from this to the next line I'm going
to ask you if you ever see something
like this too right
what this actually equals don't just
make it disappear it actually is
something it's just so happens that
that's something is one okay it's a very
parallel problem to this if you remember
this guy I should have made their necks
actually sign X on X you remember this
limit this is a really common limit that
you have to deal with back in to you in
extension one you want to say that
that's one if there's a two here you
want to say that's two times one so you
should show your understanding of that
limit being something it doesn't just
disappear okay once you get to this
sooner you can see the difference right
between my answer and your answer this
is the absolute value of x why it's
greater than four okay now if I gave you
I'm gonna come over here I have just
that space if I gave you something like
this right this guy is important to me
because it's gonna form part of the
boundary right this is an inequality but
the equation forms like the boundary
lines that can find that inequality
right now this guy's quite good to draw
because we're really familiar with this
shape this of course is the old familiar
hyperbola right cool
but I have an absolute value sign here
so that's not the only part of the
boundary what's the other part when you
have the absolute value of a right what
that means is sometimes it's just a
sometimes the absolute value of XY is
just X Y but sometimes it's not what
else can it be equal to Y a negative a
depending on what when is it just equal
to a okay it's positive it very much and
what about this one if a is yeah and
somewhere in there you include the zero
it doesn't really matter as you know
okay now for that reason how do I
interpret when
this thing equal to when is the absolute
value of XY when is it equal to minus XY
and not just XY on what condition look
at how I did right it's if this thing
inside is negative if XY is negative now
think about this right
where would x times y give me a negative
hmm
let's have a look over in this area here
this quadrant right x and y are both
positive yeah so x times y will give me
a positive so this is not that this
doesn't satisfy that right right over
here over in this region here X is
negative but Y is positive so the sine
of X y therefore will be negative so I
want this area can you tell me now
biologically working out where's the
other area yeah fourth quadrant very
good down here okay so in here I want
this graph not this one and it's the
same deal but opposite I want this graph
in these quadrants are you okay with
that alright so now you can actually
draw a set of axes I will get some space
myself have you guys already drawn your
so Baxter and Roy
and this is what happens we've noticed
this before when you have absolute
values right you kind of get copies and
reflections and that kind of thing so
I've got this is what XY looks like that
part there and it's okay in those two
quadrants number one and number three
and then in the second and fourth
quadrants I've got minus XY which looks
like that is that okay I haven't worried
too much about scale because we can put
a point on there and label some numbers
in a second now that's very messy so I'm
going to put onto this clean one over
here now because our components of our
are branches of our graph they just
stretch off to infinity this really
divides up the entire plane this is the
imaginary axis of course and this is the
real one it divides it into well a whole
lot of different zones right so you have
to test all of your cases very carefully
I'm gonna give you a moment just to try
and work out where do you think I need
to shade do you think I need to go here
here here or here they separate to here
here here and here have a moment test
some points and see if you think it
connects or doesn't and whether you can
sense a pattern there